Am 09.06 ist Europawahl!
Und das will Jan-Christoph Oetjchen von der FDP für junge Menschen tun:
Da muss man natürlich als 1. auf die Grundfreiheiten eingehen.
Mit der EU könnt ihr euch in Europa frei bewegen. Die EU macht möglich,
dass man überall mit der gleichen Währung bezahlt.
Dass ihr studieren könnt und arbeiten könnt,  wie ihr wollt.
Dass eure Rechte auch in anderen Ländern gelten.
Aber
für junge Menschen ist natürlich das Erasmus Plus Programm besonders wichtig.
Dass es Möglichkeiten der Finanzierung für das Studium im Ausland gibt,
Dass Austausche ermöglicht werden.
Wir als freie Demokraten wünschen uns,
dass wir Erasmus Plus noch stärker noch mehr ausweiten.
Beispielsweise im Bereich der Auszubildenden,
beispielsweise im Bereich der Schule,
da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten aber diese sind noch nicht genug entwickelt.
Das ist unsere Forderung, um Europa noch besser zu machen für Junge Leute